je ne sais pas si vous faites des petits
postes instagram mais moi je peux vous
le dire je vais m'y mettre parce que on
peut gagner beaucoup beaucoup à diou
d'argent pardon je la mets 2 qui mois
ci pour beaucoup d'habits l'art est
simplement une starlette de la
téléréalité la plus jeune génération
c'est qu'en quelques années elle a
réussi le pari de devenir une femme
puissante de le monde de l' influence
s'étend à jalousie je tends mon jacuzzi
prince ça me fascine les paparazzis ses
actions déchaîne les passions et ses
placements produits lui rapporte des
millions je suis riche si à la télé elle
a régulièrement signer des contrats
autour de quatre cent mille euros pour
participer à des émissions de télévision
amazon lui a proposé un million d'euros
pour la présentation de love island
mais incontestablement ce qui fait
appartenir nabila auxerre très
privilégié des millionnaires ce sont ces
placements de produits sur les réseaux
sociaux des ventes flash sont
actuellement sur le site selon le
magazine voici la star tu serais chaque
mois pas moins de quatre cent mille
euros soit environ 4 8 millions d'euros
par an contrairement à nous on ne peut
pas dire qu'elle perd son taux sur
instagram
[Musique]
les chiffres sont astronomiques petit
bémol le programme hier soir n'a pas
fonctionné et non seulement y a pas
fonctionné mais je n'ai généralement
avant quand il y avait on parle et
nabila sur les réseaux s'était tout de
suite en top tweets et hier ça a été le
calme plat oui parce que c'est un peu
lui très jeune en tout cas j'ai enquêté
sur les chiffres ils sont exacts nabila
400000 euros par mois le couple nabila
est thomas 650000 euros par mois et ça
c'est uniquement les placements de
produits qu'elle est aussi une marque de
beauté à la sonde il avec amazon en plus
et pour info les influences world iv
télé réalité issue date et la nature la
réputation d' accepter tout et n'importe
quoi pour faire de l'argent il refuse
pour un contrat star qui choisissent les
marques par me anne marque de sextoys
qui les a contactés récemment ils ont
refusé donc ils prennent pas tous les
contrats ils sont hyper sélectifs et
avec ça ils réussissent à gagner
beaucoup d'argent donc franchement bravo
guillaume tu dis une bêtise parce que je
crois que thomas ne fait plus de
placement de produit interdit de poster
sur instagram y reviendrons fait sur les
réseaux sociaux il sera choix qu'ils
sont déportés molle sur tik tok ça ouais
tik tok snapshot si son style sont
surtout les réseaux ils sont très
puissants franchement ça c'est un modèle
de réussite un nouveau modèle les
franchement je sais qu'on compte les
bouses guillaume l'a donc sa fin du
marché qu'on compte les bouses sur cinq
six ans à ce jugement
5-6 ans à 4000 euros par mois 420 alors
elle a touché 2 millions pour un truc
d'amazon alors amazonia une bouche
d'égout thaïlande il ya un million
d'exclusivité en plus ça fait 2 millions
comme 1,2 million de 2 millions d'euros
c'est elle qui lui donne elle a très
bien
fait toujours marrer quand on débat il
de l'argent de l'argent frais c'est une
belle réussite parce qu'au départ on
habille la
butte en france et seul truc c'est des
vrais pourrait payer des impôts en
france et nous sommes solidaires quand
elle dit en français c'est cambrioler
excusez moi que les bleus risquent
habitants fanta les bars histoire
blu-ray talent et lagardère pendant
d'accord mais a laissé
invitant à 400000 euros à la commune en
voyage et des bars un truc sécurisé
c'est quand même pas le rebelle de
démocratie non plus encore quand même
particulier pas de s'installer là bas là
c'est vrai que l'on va dire que c'est
voilà on peut on peut critiquer
attendait elle ne gagne pas elle elle
fait pâle c'est pas son argent en france
en faisant des concerts à bercy ou ou
son territoire a fait des postes les
potes c'est mondiale guillaume on est
d'accord elle pose sur le monde entier
lui qui la suivait
mois elle pose pas pour des manades
habite à dubaï pour l'instant elle en
train de déjouer un système fiscal ou 6
contre fiscale l'adaqoa fiscal des
discours voilà si elle veut déjouer ça
d'accord pour moi ça me dérange pas
qu'il reste à dubaï le truc c'est qu'il
ne sera pas dubaï elle va revenir en
france et même impasse du temps france
c'est ça que je rejoins steevy c'est
dérangeant parce que elle va se servir
du système français quand ce sera
l'éducation quand ce sera la santé est
la maladie la session mais qu'at il à
moi